the gates of the north will be opened up
and out will come the powers of the
nations which were enclosed within and
the whole earth will reel from their
face and men will cry aloud and flee and
hide themselves in the mountains and in
the caves among the gravestones and they
will be deadened with fear and many will
perish for none will be to bury its
bodies for the nations coming from the
north eat the flesh of men and drink the
blood of beasts like water and eat
unclean things snakes and scorpions and
all abominable and disgusting beasts and
the reptiles that creep upon the earth
and brutal things and dead bodies and
the aborted fetuses of women and they
will slaughter infants even producing
them from their womb wombs and they will
boil the meat and eat it and they will
corrupt the earth and befall it and
deface it and there will be no one able
to stand before them
um and basically this is the thing that
precipitates the end
[Music]
[Applause]
this is jonathan pedro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Music]
[Laughter]
so hello everybody we are here with
richard roland once again
and uh he's wearing some great symbolic
world merch of uh ethiopian cross which
will be related to what we're going to
talk about today because today we're
going to talk about
the
we're going to talk about gog and magog
we're going to talk about the crazy
hordes
of nomads which come down from the steps
and devastate the world and how this was
inscribed mythologically in in our
different texts and also how it kind of
played out historically so richard
thanks for coming i'm excited about this
yeah this is going to be um
i mean this is one of those this is one
of those topics where there's like a
kind of meta symbolism at play uh which
is when you start trying to talk about
the symbolism of the step hordes
there is a
literal flood of information that just
kind of comes overwhelming and makes it
impossible to talk about in any kind of
a structured way but we're going to do
our best in it
so
yeah
so let's start we're going to start with
going back into the apocalypse of
pseudomethodius because this has kind of
been in some ways a an example of a
universal history which was extremely
influential both in the in the east and
the west and which has all these kind of
narrative mythological images which can
help us understand you know kind of how
we can link actual historical events to
this grand narrative uh so so start us
off richard yeah so
to dial things back even a little bit
further than that um
in the
in the book of ezekiel the prophet
ezekiel chapter 38 we get this reference
to
uh says son of man set thy face against
gog the land of magog the chief prince
of meshech and tubal and prophesy
against him so this is
a prophecy against
basically the barbarian hordes of
northern europe
and
just as one example the uh the the
jewish roman historian josephus
identifies gog and magog with uh or gog
from magog yeah which is what it is here
in ezekiel um identifies that with
scythia right so the scythians are a
um they're a group of
uh
essentially uh well they're they're an
ancient nomadic people uh who lived in
or who came from the region that today
is what we call kazakhstan
um but they were they're you know
basically on the russian steps of the of
the of siberia in eastern ukraine
and um they invaded uh during the
classical period they invaded the pontic
step
um and that's kind of how they came into
contact with the biblical world
um they're probably an iranian people in
origin and anyway the main thing to
understand is they are a uh they were an
aggressive
nomadic people
um
they were they they wrote on horseback
back they shot bows and pretty much all
the people that we talk about today are
going to be aggressive nomadic people
who wrote on horseback and shot bows
and so this is back in the time of
ezekiel you know and it gets carried
forward to the the it gets carried
forward to for instance the book of
revelation uh revelation chapter 20
verse eight when gog and magog so
there's it sort of changes the hebrew
gog from magog to gog and magog but it
um
where they're seen as this these
barbarian hordes of the north right and
so we talked a little bit last time
about if you draw a map facing east then
the north is on your left hand right and
if you're a lord of spirits listener for
instance you know that north is the
liturgical direction
from which evil comes from which
darkness comes from which the enemy
comes and there are still some christian
traditions today that actually for this
reason certain certain services they
read the the gospel
facing north because it's a proclamation
of the victory of christ to the enemies
of god at the enemies the people of god
who sort of historically come down out
of the north if you lived in the levant
right so we talked about this is a
jerusalem-centered view of the world
if you go to other cultures you'll find
that other cultures have their
traditional
direction of evil is going to be maybe
situated differently depending on
where they're from
yeah so but there's a general there's a
general notion in that the west and the
north are somewhat sinister because
the west is the place where the sun goes
down and the north is the place where
the sun never goes so the north is
naturally dark in in its the way that we
actually experience it and not only that
but the way we experience the north is
also related to
um to the cold and to you know desolate
areas in terms of the the north pole but
also in terms of mountains like we
always have to understand the way that
that even even in um
even in israel like looking north they
would have had those mountains that
would have been right with the white
caps and so yeah sort of that that whole
that whole uh that psalm that says i i
lift up mine eyes unto the hills and it
was towards the north from where does my
help come that's that's uh those are two
separate phrases sometimes english
translations make it sound like
the the
it is the hills from whence my help is
coming but it's the other way around
it's like i'm looking at the hills i'm
looking at the mountains i'm looking
towards the north who's going to help me
who's going to save me right
is what that solomon's asking so yeah um
the basic idea here is that you have uh
hordes of barbarian nomads um barbarians
being you know anyone who doesn't speak
greek or
or just uh you know
and then much later on the usage just
means people who are situated outside of
that sort of roman household the roman
world
so you've got hordes of barbarian nomads
and uh typically speaking the nomads are
are are horse archers right um
which
i don't know how nerdy you want to get
here um because i was super i'm still
super into this stuff when i was a kid i
would go to the library and just check
out every single book they had on horse
nomads because i've always found them
like one of the most
uh
fascinating
uh
phenomena of history um this you know
this basic
you know basically you have one piece of
technology which is the the the
composite recurve bow
right and that one piece of technology
makes possible
the largest land empire that has ever
existed in human history yeah and
obviously everyone knows uh i heart the
romans um you know you gotta love your
parents right so like for all the things
that are messed up about rome and and
for all the good things too like i love
roman history
but i gotta give it to the mongols here
you know if you're just going going like
sheer size of empire you know maybe not
so much lasting cultural
artifacts but
sheer size of empire like the mongols
have it for sure yeah and um
it's also interesting to read about the
horse archers because of the the madness
of the account like some of the accounts
make them sound like these superheroes
even their own accounts the way that
they describe the amount of arrows
they're able to shoot like the idea of
catching an arrow midair and putting it
in your bow and shooting it back that
kind of crazy stuff i mean that is just
amazing yeah that stuff is that stuff is
awesome yeah the stuff is just awesome
like yeah so i'm i'm super into this
stuff uh several years ago
there there was this amazing genghis
khan exhibit that was uh
touring the country and i came to dallas
and so i took to my wife and
some of my family members and uh that
was amazing and they had a bunch of like
his stuff like his armor
some of his arrows things like this all
there um and then there were like three
people that showed up to do
like the throat singing you know oh yeah
yeah yeah which was
yeah which is super cool so anyway all
that to say um this has been uh
something i've been really interested in
for a long period of time and so when i
talk about this stuff
um it's definitely from a place of of
love and as much as is appropriate a
place of admiration obviously there's a
lot about the mongols
that would not be admirable from like
any kind of a civilized point of view
um
all the genocide for instance you know
like the
it's a little problem
yeah but um but for all that you know
it's a really fascinating historical uh
uh
you know area of study i guess you could
say so
um and actually if somebody wants to
uh if somebody wants to
just like really take a deep dive into
just mongol history uh from a kind of a
mongolian point of view yeah dan
carlin's hardcore history podcast um
there's a uh
he's got a series on the mongols and i
don't know if it's still free you might
have to pay for it but even if you do
pay for it it's totally worth it's
pretty long
so you get a lot of hours of listening a
lot of days listening out of it
and uh he goes into really deep detail
on a whole bunch of facets of mongolian
history there are a few things in there
that when i was listening to it i was
like i don't think that's quite right
and so i wouldn't check like primary
sources that i have access to and know
about it's like ah no he got this this
little detail wrong or something but
on the whole it's quite good so yeah
people might want to check that out
all right so you got this so now we've
got gog and magog inscribed in
revelation now moving into the alexander
yeah legend or corpus yeah so we talked
about the alexander romance uh quite a
bit and they it's really like some
people have said alexander romance is
not so much a text as it is like a genre
because they're actually a whole lot of
different alexander legends uh there's a
syriac one that is quite important um
although i don't think there's a really
a good english translation of it uh
right now but there is a there's a there
are some pretty good greek editions that
will also have the interpolations for
the syriac is different they'll include
that and there's
a pretty decent one from from penguin
classics i think
um so in the alexander romance and in
other works that refer to it i mean uh
obviously the apocalypse of
pseudo-methodist one we've been talking
about this is right here towards the
beginning
we have alexander the great
do something that is actually going to
um
i don't know if it's the very first
precedent for this but it's definitely
it sets a certain pattern which then
lots of uh which then
we'll see play out historically in a lot
of different ways and places and so what
what he does there's this the story of
the gates of alexander and i think in
our very first ethiopia video we
actually talked about this
but the the gates of alexander the idea
is that he goes up and there are a few
different um
you know geographical formations that
were later named the gates of alexander
and they're actually
actual walls and gates that were named
the gates of alexander for instance the
persians built one in i want to say the
sixth century
and uh they called it the wall of
alexander like they were very very
conscious remember like alexander
everybody gets to claim alexander
because he's he's he was the king of
everything you know yeah back then and
people
yeah indian
they're like
legends and then and uh and obviously
yeah islamic legends much later and and
all these so everybody kind of quran
like there's yeah in the in the quran
yes
in the quran i mean and this this story
of alexander's gates is is in the quran
as well i believe yeah although he's got
a different name he's not called
alexander
yeah yeah so anyway um
so the idea is alexander goes and he
builds these unbreakable gates and for
instance in the uh you know the gates
are usually made out of oracalcum or
some other kind of magical metal yeah
like an alloy like a weird yeah
yeah some kind of a weird alloy because
the idea is
uh it's got to be magic proof because
the people that he's
he's uh
sort of banishing beyond the the
furthest reaches of human civilization
they're monsters they're
um and we can go into all kinds of ways
in which they are monsters you know the
different texts describe them
differently the thing that they all tend
to have in common is that they're
cannibals sometimes they have the heads
of dogs that eat uh bugs
they um
they eat you know aborted
babies and like all this different stuff
like they're really monstrous you know
and they're banished beyond the they're
banished beyond you can just understand
the gates of alexander as being like the
furthest point of human civilization
right so there's like there's like human
civilization including like the
the edge and then
beyond the edge there's the wall
and beyond the wall there's monsters
yeah and we can we need to understand it
as really a mythological representation
of something which has many
historical iterations some which precede
the the the the apocalypse and some
which come later you know whether it be
the chinese wall whether it be the
different walls in in uh in the uk uh
yeah yeah so this is virgin wall like
this this is the third region
yeah this is the thing that i want to
wanted to point out is that historically
in the east there were several different
walls which were built obviously there's
the great wall of china uh alexander's
wall which is the second i think the
second largest wall uh ever built
um
and actually
bigger in uh than some of the early
sections of the great wall of china um
but
uh that was built in built by the
persians to keep out a group called the
white huns
um and uh but then yeah you've got the
same thing going on in the uk um yeah
the anthony wall and the hadrian's wall
yeah yeah they build
two different walls to keep
keep out the pics and the other
you know the really crazy really out
there barbarian civilizations that were
like you know england you know the
island of britain that's the edge of the
roman world
literal the edge of the roman world but
there's crazier stuff beyond that like
monsters beyond that and they built
walls to try to try to keep that stuff
out and of course the
the uh
the story of all of these walls is that
eventually they fail
um you know eventually they fail and
they usually fail because people
people stop keeping the watch or people
were bought off you know people were
bribed um or or or the you know they
didn't have money to maintain the wall
anymore or something like that like it's
always it's always you know not a
failure of you could say like the
physical structure itself but a failure
of the vigilance failure yeah failure of
attention
yeah failure of attention and so they um
and so something happens they stop
keeping the watch on the wall
and that's when the monsters start
coming in
and um
and so
this is like kind of the basic pattern
of gog and magog and it it basically
informs the way
that the levantine world
uh by by when i say the levante world i
mean both the christian
um the jewish and also the the uh the
islamic world of the middle east during
the middle ages
that this this colors that affects the
way that they think about and experience
these step hordes which from their
perspective are coming kind of out of
the east and out of the north um
and we talked a little bit last time
about um
for scandinavian peoples who at a
slightly earlier uh who at slightly
earlier juncture in history were gog and
magog right um that's that's the
um that's the thing to say about this
this idea of gog and magog is a little
flexible
right
the way i like to talk about it that
it's a category like friend and stranger
right so the category of stranger when i
say that's a stranger it's a it's a
category which is true and which exists
but that but finds body and whatever
embodies it and so yeah it's almost like
the word barbarian itself the word
barbarian doesn't actually uh it's not a
it's not like an ethnic word it's a word
talks about that which is outside and so
i think gog and magog
seems to play that role as well yeah a
kind of uh a weird or goofy or uh maybe
even at this point in history a
sensitive example of this um just so
that we say nothing at all controversial
in jonathan's channel is is uh when i
was growing up you know growing up in
this evangelical setting um the you know
in the south in in uh
in the south of north america
um
in the american south uh
so i live in the dallas area and uh
dallas is actually the home
of the origin point of a kind of
theology called dispensationalism which
all that left behind stuff the rapture
stuff
um
[Music]
we invented that yeah you're all welcome
yeah you're all welcome everyone like
where would you guys be without like a
nicolas cage remake of a kirk cameron
movie i mean that is a thing that is the
thing that happened like people i don't
know it's yeah it's pretty amazing uh
but
and so in this in this kind of
dispensationalist point of view i mean i
can remember when i was a kid i would
just chuck out
i i read every book in in our church
library we had a um i don't know if
that's a thing that
a lot of the churches that i grew up and
had like a church library yeah
[Music]
at my parish now we have a church
bookstore which is not quite the same
thing um but um but we had a church
library and you could uh and actually i
volunteered at the at the church library
surprising to everyone um i volunteered
at the church library so i would go and
i would i would work there on sunday
afternoons after church to help people
check books out and check books back in
and contact people who are late on their
books and so on
and um
anyway so
the uh but this church library was
mostly books about
the end times pro about end times
prophecy i mean that was it was a very
small room there were probably 2 300
books and they were mostly about end
times prophecy and at some point in the
process of my childhood i read all of
these books wow i was just really
fascinated by this stuff and one of the
things that um
uh you know i read this one book and the
thing is like i didn't know how old some
of these books were like a lot of these
books were written in like the 70s and
80s
so
yeah and so this is the thing this is
this is where this long and rambly story
is going is that i would read this story
and it you know and it you know i'm
reading a book that's written during the
cuban missile crisis right and so gog
and magog are cuba and russia
and then i'd go home and i'd be like
really freaked out i'm like dad do you
know about these missiles in cuba and
all this stuff and he'd be like
actually that
that happened like a long time ago and
it's not you know when you know to
happen before you were born it's not a
problem now it's you know but yeah so so
this is the thing is that that gog and
magog were
you know russia and china or russia and
cuba or you know they're basically like
whatever
whoever the other is whoever the enemy
is whatever the sort of unknown
um and and it's kind of like uh
it
i mean in in currently like political
correct critical race theory discourse
and things like that there's this
there's a lot of talk about not othering
people
right but there's there's something to
that
right and what i mean by that is
is basically as soon as as soon as like
something becomes really familiar to you
uh you could say as soon as it becomes
sort of domesticated
um
you know so as so if you uh if you don't
know i mean for instance you know russia
is the bad guy you know right now in
america so like if you don't know a
whole lot about
russian politics or culture things like
this then it's really easy and and
obviously this russia is gog and magog
stuff has been making the rounds again
right because of that um if you do know
a lot about the political situation over
there then you might not you know
uh
you could say oh this war is terrible we
need to pray for these people all this
stuff but but in your mind they're the
sort of they're other human beings
nations have wars all the time
we need to pray for the situation but
but there's not that that not that same
sense that you know they're the
barbarian horde on the edge of the world
right so it's
it's uh so this is an identity that is
always kind of looking for a home you
could say yeah well that's why that's
why one of the reasons why emphasizing
christopher so much is because i think
that the iconos and christopher md the
story of saint christopher is a way to
both acknowledge the strangeness
but then give you a method by which to
to domesticate it and then engage it so
i think that that's it's important to
understand that and i what you see in
the old pentecost icons is something
like that too which is like we
acknowledge the strangeness of the of
the the foreigner but then we don't we
don't see that as an absolute limit like
it is possible to slowly enter into
contact with them and that and then
yeah kind of bring them into our bring
them into a relationship but that's not
a but it's so it's not it's when people
say don't bother others like don't other
than that's like you can't do that we're
made that way like this is something
that we do automatically if you don't
realize that you do it then you'll do it
unconsciously
uh and and you won't even realize just
as you're criticizing people from for
othering you'll be doing it at the same
time right um exactly right better to
recognize it as a normal mechanism of
perception that we see strange things as
kind of monstrous kind of hybrid you
know off-key and then how is it then
that now we can domesticate that to the
extent that it's possible sometimes you
also don't because i'm
there are some strange things that are
dangerous for you you know it's like
that that really could so if you if you
see a dark stranger in an alleyway you
know you don't know who it is but you
might not want to domesticate that dark
stranger in an alleyway it might be
better to walk away because that dark
stranger in the alleyway might just kill
you you know yeah i mean weird food is
another great example um i mean i grew
up eating uh in kind of like an asian
american household uh so kind of living
in these two worlds we ate a lot of
ate a lot of chinese food like really
traditional chinese food
and a lot of traditional chinese food
and let's say like traditional poor
people food in general right
the way that the way that something like
i'll pick on you because you're french
ish
the way that the way that a snail
becomes a delicacy right you're not
supposed to eat snails you're not snails
are bugs they crawl around on the ground
they're slimy you shouldn't eat snails
but if you're poor enough you will
figure out a way to cook a snail so that
it kind of tastes good
and that's when there a flip happens and
you have all these things that used to
be basically poor people food i mean a
great example is shrimp or octopus or
any other invertebrate that comes out of
the ocean that's all trash food yeah
right that's mediterranean trash food
that's why it's that's why you're
allowed to eat it during a
fast because it's a bug right
so that's trash food it's crawling
around in the filth at the bottom of the
ocean right literally at the bottom of
the abyss right
at the bottom of hell there's a bug
crawling around eating garbage and
you're allowed to eat that but
eventually people figured out a way to
like cook that so it's really tasty
and uh and that's why like in the united
states shrimp lobster et cetera are
delicacies so
um i mean that's a good way to to
understand the process of domesticating
a certain thing but then there's stuff
that's like even beyond that a little
bit i took the kids to the dallas world
aquarium aquarium yesterday
and uh they had like a bunch of puffer
fish in the tank and i was looking
showing them the puffer fish
and unfortunately none of them got angry
at us i was hoping we'd see one of them
kind of you know pop up but
but we were talking about puffer fish i
was explaining to them how puffer fish
work and what they do and how they
protect themselves
and uh but then also explaining that you
know puffer fish are extremely toxic
and potentially lethal to eat but that
hasn't stopped them from being a
delicacy in certain asian countries yeah
um japan in particular right and so so
then that's like that's like taking that
to the very edge of what you can do in
terms of domesticating something right
but then there's stuff that nobody can
eat
right there's there's there's stuff that
nobody can integrate yeah but i think
and the images that we see in the the
way they represent gog and magog right
like that they say that they're
cannibals the fact that they say that
they that they eat human fetuses you
know like that the other images that
could be used would be incest or all
these kind of taboos that cannot be
integrated that they just can't like if
we integrate them they could destroy
society yeah yeah and and you know
drinking the blood of animals which is
actually a thing that a lot of these
nomadic tribes certainly did you know
drinking drinking mares blood uh
drinking you know eating
eating horse flesh things like that
horse flesh is a um
let's say uh uh
a a gray area when it comes to food to
booze um a lot of a lot of societies
don't eat horses for some reason that
they don't eat dogs
is like uh it's a little it's an animal
that's
a little a little too close to the human
experience in some way um but also also
unclean for you know
uh other reasons as well so
yeah um
so you've got so you've got the
symbolism of gog and mega out on the
edge you've got the gates of alexander
and then that that idea of the gates of
alexander actually manifests itself
literally a bunch of times in throughout
history right so you can i mean this is
the way to read this apocalyptic
literature is to look for the pattern
and then see the way the pattern is
manifesting
but in in the apocalypse and in the
alexander romance and in the islamic
legends the idea is that at the end of
the world
one of the things that will bring about
the end of the world or while the end of
the world is playing out
of gogen the gates of alexander will be
breached and gag and magog will be
unleashed on the world to kind of devour
it judge it all that stuff yeah yeah so
this is this idea
um
that we find in the apocalypse of
pseudo-methodius but we actually find it
way before this in in the old testament
and in the book of revelation for that
matter right in all of this apocalyptic
apocalyptic literature even in things
like the prophecy of habakkuk right what
the prophecy of habakkuk is all about
why would god use these heathen
barbarian nations in this case the neoc
what are called the neo-assyrians by
historians today in the bible they're
called the babylonians
why would god use them to
uh why would god use them to punish his
own people right isn't that
i and this is a big question i mean
there's a bunch of the ezra literature
so like um
there's a whole
there's a whole genre of of literature
in the in the second temple jewish
period around the prophet ezra and his
apocalyptic visions um and so this
starts out with a book called fourth
esdras
uh which is actually in the russian
orthodox bible
um so if you're in the russian tradition
it's in your bible you should go read it
it's actually pretty rad it's super cool
um
uh and it's all about this this idea
like why why would god use uh why would
god use unjust people to punish his own
people you know which is this question
that comes up over and over again in the
holy scriptures and then
kind of more generally like why would
god use
barbarians to punish you know roman
civilization why would god use demons to
chastise humankind things like this
right it's it's that same question kind
of over and over again
and we see that
um we see that question kind of
expressed here like that's one of the
main things the apocalypse of
pseudo-methodius is dealing with
the
the the time of this of the writing here
is probably
during the muslim conquest of much of
the levant and much of the byzantine
world
and so that's one of the things that the
author is trying to really come to terms
with is to say
why are we
what's going on here what happened to
the you know the kingdom of god what's
going on
which is also a question that a lot
earlier for instance augustine is trying
to answer said augustine try to answer
when he writes the city of god right
it's the same same kind of a question
when we're confronted with history that
doesn't seem to be going the way we
think it should we have to sort of
we have to step back and get this
apocalyptic perspective and that's what
an apocalypse is for it's to show you
here are the patterns of the ends of
things but also the the larger pattern
of how god is working in the world and
so
this is what it says it says that um
[Music]
after the
the conquest of uh
of visas or you know there's the
byzantines
by ishmael and ishmael's children
um
that he's going to
uh he'll he'll eventually be defeated uh
ishmael will eventually be defeated and
he'll be defeated by two things one will
be the
resurgence of the king of the romans
coming out of ethiopia which you've
already talked about
and then the other thing um the other
thing that's going to happen is going to
be that the gates of the north will be
opened up
and out will come the powers of the
nations which were enclosed within and
the whole earth will reel from their
face and men will cry aloud and flee and
hide themselves in the mountains and in
the caves among the gravestones and they
will be deadened with fear and many will
perish for none will be to bury its
bodies for the nations coming from the
north eat the flesh of men and drink the
blood of beasts like water and eat
unclean things snakes and scorpions and
all abominable and disgusting beasts and
the reptiles that creep upon the earth
and brutal things and dead bodies and
the aborted fetuses of women and they
will slaughter infants even producing
them from their womb wombs and they will
boil the meat and eat it and they will
corrupt the earth and befall it and to
face it and there will be no one able to
stand before them
um and basically this is the thing that
priest precipitates the end um the king
of the romans after this shortly he he
he gives up the kingdom we've talked
about this already he gives up the
kingdom to god and when he gives up the
kingdom of god the antichrist appears
and then the end comes right
so um
this so there's this idea that as part
of the end of you could say like the end
of a cycle or the end of a period or the
end of the world right as part of part
of what happens at the end
is that the barrier
is broken down and all the things that
you were keeping out
they show up and they show up
they show up uh
as this powerful destructive force
but also as sort of a um you know what
saint gregory nissa would refer to as
the left hand of god
right is they they show up and and their
destruction is not without a purpose
right yeah that it becomes sort of like
a
um like a wildfire
right where it kind of burns down all
the stuff
that shouldn't you know all the
corruption all the decadence that's
building up yeah and also a flood it's
really related to the flood yeah yeah
yeah definitely related to the idea of
the flood that comes but people like and
i think just maybe to kind of point to
the symbolic aspect how people
understand that this is really the
description of death in general it's a
description of how something ends so you
have a
that's what death is when the outside
things
finally break in that's what death is so
you are there your your body you're
fighting the outside your your body is
holding together and kind of let's say
integrating some outside things you know
ejecting some some things but then at
some point your body stops to do that
and then the worms the things everything
breaks apart and everything from the
outside comes in and then there's no
difference between the inside and the
outside you basically decompose and so
this image of the barbarians coming in
finally breaking the barrier
that's what it is it's the same thing
like i have an apple falling to the
ground and then ultimately it starts to
to get mushy and finally it breaks down
and then
the inside and the outside coalesce but
it also is a breaking down which can
produce fertile ground for a new
beginning at the same time right that's
just a natural pattern of things did you
ever read uh
the last battle like the final narnia
book
i read it when i was like 11. that that
book is like
one of the most insightful books to read
if you just want to see the pattern of
the end of the thing
and and this is one of the things that
happens at the very end as the i mean
it's you know starts with
you know it starts with the the ape
which is like a false man and the donkey
which is like a false lion and all this
stuff uh really beautiful symbolism um
we should we should like read that and
talk about it one day because i think
people would would really think out of
it
but um
uh but what you know as
the as the world is ending as narnia is
is kind of ending you know the stars
fall out of the sky
um of course in narnia just like in our
world stars are our people and um
and maybe not just like in our world but
similarly
and uh
so as but so one of the things that
happens as the world is ending is that
there are all these monsters that live
in the northern wastes okay so it's
again in the north and this is the nice
thing about narnia um if you're trying
to
get it get a sense of things and like a
biblical you know a biblical cosmology
or framework narnia is also east facing
which means all your bad stuff comes out
of the north because it's to the left
and um uh whereas whereas
for reasons we talked about in the
previous video
tolkien's legendarium for instance is
west facing um although bad guys also
live in the north in in in the legend in
tolkien's legendarium but um but the but
the really scary stuff comes out of the
east yeah so um
uh but all these monsters and they're
just they're described as being like
dragons giant lizards giant snakes all
these different things
they're at the very end of things
they are
released out of the north and they come
down and they just eat everything until
there's nothing but barren rock
and then they die yeah right and the
idea is it's just like a cleaning or
like a scouring
um that that takes place and uh this is
one of these things you know louis
louis's symbolic intuition was really
strong in certain places so definitely
yeah that'd be a fun book to look at
sometime i keep coming across things
that i'm like you know if we did a
symbolic world uh like like a
read-through kind of like a universal
history reading club or something like
that there's some stuff that would be
kind of fun to go over that'd be great
yeah so all right we have the
description of these monsters barbarians
that are up in us
and then then we have
examples like let's say fractal examples
of that happening when these these
groups pour in from the steps and
basically ravage
society you know try to turn society
into grazing pasture basically yeah so
the earliest uh furthest examples of
this
were basically the uh the germanic
peoples the uh in in western european
history this is what is referred to as
the barbarian invasion starts in fifth
and sixth centuries um and it is what
basically precipitates the breakdown of
the western half of the roman empire
there are a bunch of different people
groups that are involved in this and
basically you get successive waves
because basically you have one really
big group in the back which was the huns
and they're pushing all the other groups
forward and so it's like you have a most
monstrous group and then they're pushing
the second most monstrous group who are
pushing the third who are pushing forth
so you start out by having oh you think
these people are really uncivilized but
actually they're kind of civilized
because they've lived in contact with
roman civilization for a long time and
those guys in fade and they invade and
they settle
and then what the romans end up doing is
hiring those guys to fight the next wave
of invaders yeah and that's a great i
mean that if you want to understand an
image of reality that's a really that's
a good uh yeah
itself and it's a way that uh you could
say and then uh
this civ that it's it's how civilization
puts on garments of skins you could say
is like taking the taking the you know
like a literal garment of skin would be
something like i kill an animal and i
wear skin yeah right so
you have this you have this you know
basically i i integrate a new
civilization and i wear that
civilization skin so i i um
i mean this happened in the united
states when the quakers came and settled
pennsylvania um big shout out to the the
forest of william penn i'll be there uh
next week with father andrew um but um
uh when the quakers settled pennsylvania
they had all these problems with
uh with the native americans that were
living around them because quakers are
pacifists and turns out the native
americans were not
and uh so they what they did is they
invited all of these scotch irish to
come and settle on either side of them
right the scotch irish being famously
bellicose people you know uh because
they didn't want to fight so they they
took somebody who was like a little more
barbaric than they were
and settled them on either side of them
yes so that they would have somebody to
do their fighting you know for them so i
mean this is a thing that that this is
it's a thing that happens
and um
it can help you understand then that
when you're dealing with this problem of
identity there are two things
there are two things you want to do one
is you want to you always have to
understand the function of the fringe on
the edge because the fringe on the edge
can sometimes be a little annoying
but if you get rid of it there's a
bigger fringe waiting for you behind it
so that's why you always have to be
careful when you remove you'd say the
things that don't fit from your society
because behind that are things that
really don't fit and not only don't fit
but actually want to devour you yeah
yeah yep
so uh in the roman empire the way this
worked is they would br as these
barbarian tribes invaded they would
fight them for a little bit and then
eventually they would buy them off they
would buy them off and pay them to fight
the next wave and obviously there are a
lot of historians uh
gibbon is the most famous one who wrote
the decline and fall of the roman empire
and he basically sees the the decline
and fall of the roman empire which he
really sees as being the western empire
he did not have any kind of a love for
for the east
um but he uh he basically sees the
decline in the fall of the roman empire
as being a result of two things one is
christianity coming and emasculating
good rom you know hard roman virtue
um uh didn't not a big fan of
christianity was was yes we know that
yeah and then but then the other thing
that you saw as being a major cause of
the downfall of the empire was the way
that they were hiring
uh that that the way that they weren't
you know producing their own soldiers
anymore they kept hiring new barbarian
mercenaries but i mean the sort of
problem with that is is that uh the
thing i think gibbon didn't understand
super well is that this is just this is
the normal pattern like in in america
today for instance our military is is a
is an entirely volunteer force right and
so and and of course living in the
united states and especially in the
south there is certainly a tendency to
kind of glorify our military uh where i
live for instance yesterday here from
when we're recording this in the states
was memorial day which is a day to
remember and and if you're an orthodox
christian it's also a day to pray for uh
fallen american soldiers
nothing wrong with that
however
we sort of forget that historically the
reality has been
you do your army is not made up of
your best people
armies tend to be made up of the people
who cannot fit in society otherwise
right the the let's say the dog-headed
men in your in your society and you said
those are the guys that you send out to
fight the bigger monsters on the edge
right and so this is the same pattern
the same pattern that was happening in
rome during the late republic period but
now it's just being extended further
right toward as as the empire reaches
its end
and so um the big the two biggest groups
that come in um the first one is the
goths who cause all kinds of trouble for
rome um
they cause all kinds of trouble for
christianity uh in that the goths are uh
when they were evangelized they were
primarily evangelized by aryans you know
they were coming they were they were
invading and coming into contact with
rome
uh really right during that period of
you know the aryan controversy so a lot
of them were evangelized by aryans
um
although also they they actually in an
ironic twist they also killed the last
aryan emperor in battle so there you go
salt so they sort of solved that problem
but also caused it caused another
problem and uh the goths in spain
particularly the visigoths remained
uh remained aryan for a really long time
and there are some people who who
believe or say that the filioque
originated uh in what in spain and the
iberian peninsula as a way to kind of
combat this mysterious among the gods
yeah which is probably probably true so
um all that to say
you've got the goss and then behind the
goss come the last big scary group of
this long procession of barbarians and
that is the huns right yeah so i think
most people like even if you don't know
the details of the hunnic invasion of
the roman empire like you probably have
heard of attila the hunt yeah the image
you have
somewhere in your mind yeah
yeah right like it's a it's a i mean
that is a cultural memory which has left
such a deep scar in all peoples of
western european or northern european
descent
or eastern european for that matter um
and
mean the thing about the huns is like we
don't even totally know who they were
um they were certainly a big
confederation of tribes but for instance
a lot of the hanukkah names that we have
attila being a good example are actually
gothic
so um so they were basically there were
goths fighting the huns but there were
probably also a bunch of goths among the
huns right so at the very end it was
just this big
conglomeration that had sort of picked
up had probably started in what is now
mongolia but as it made its way across
eurasia and ended up in western europe
it had just picked up all of these other
people groups as they went so attila's
name uh this is fun uh actually is a
gothic word for little daddy um so it
was like uh probably like a term of
endearment from his from his gothic
soldiers yeah
yeah but he's also known as the scourge
of god yeah he's also known as the
scourge of god yeah and i mean it's one
of the great
moments in history is when he's invading
he's marching towards rome
and uh
uh the pope
goes out
yeah he goes out to to meet him and they
have some kind of a conversation
and a tillage turns around it's so
that's that's like one of the most
mysterious moments in history you can't
trying to understand what happened there
it's very difficult yeah
yeah i mean really quite amazing but
something to say about attila and this
will be also true for genghis khan much
later in history
is that attila
was very conscious
of the role that he was playing
uh in terms of being the sort of left
hand of god right so he let's say he
leaned into this scourge of god identity
right um and of course attila had had
grown up
uh
let's say he was no stranger to roman
culture he's no stranger to christianity
right um
there had been like some fostering and
hostage swapping and things like that
that had gone on during his childhood so
he'd spent a lot of time around romans
and he had basically like foster
brothers who were the sons of of roman
consuls and emperors and things like
this
so he was no no stranger to roman
culture no stranger to christianity and
he and he was very familiar with like he
he understood the role that he was
playing and he really kind of leaned
into it
um and and of course he's eventually
defeated and driven back at a very
famous battle
and um
but
his his invasion i mean that sets you
know the earliest
uh the earliest uh
no the earliest bit of germanic poetry
that we have the earliest bit of norse
poetry that we have is this poem called
the battle of the goths and the huns
like it's the very that's the very
oldest bit of written poetry that we
have
you know from that society so
it it left like a deep deep memory
in all of these different cultures
so much later on
um you have the mongols and before we
talk about the moguls this is a good
place to introduce so we have this idea
of we have this idea of gog and magog
right coming out of the north we also
have this idea of professor john and we
talked a little bit about professor john
at the end of the last video
the idea of presser john is basically
this this idea of that there's this king
who is in the extreme east or maybe the
extreme south sometimes he's in ethiopia
other times he's
uh in india
and we talked about how for the reasons
for which those are kind of the same
location in the roman world
um and uh
he's
uh the the title prester in english this
is an adaptation of
of the greek word for priest
as an and and it's a it's it's a it's a
cognate with our own word priest
and the basic idea of president john is
that he's this king of the east but he's
a priest king
now the whole priest king thing is a
um
this is one thing that tells you that he
is
uh legendary or mythical but also that
tells you that he sort of belongs to
uh
another world or like another more
extreme world because like the you know
there are lots of priest kings in the
ancient world and then in the in the
kingdom of israel
priests the priesthood and the kingship
those gets
more or less permanently separated and
they are only actually unified in christ
right and so the idea is that there's
this melchizedek priesthood is this
really ancient priesthood
one of these days we should talk about
melchizedek um because there's all kinds
of yeah a lot of freaky legends which
maybe they can't
maybe they cannot or should not talk
about on lord of spirits but we can
definitely talk about in this context um
there's some weird stuff around
man but um
uh so so there's this idea that there's
this king out there this king in the
east and um
the
this you know and and these legends are
predicated on these ideas the reason we
laid all the groundwork we did last time
right is because there's this idea there
was this fourth son of noah who was
enlightened he went to the far east
there is this um there is this king of
india that was evangelized by the
apostle thomas right so there's all
these different legends especially in
syrian christianity of a king in the
east yeah so but you can also understand
that there were
that the professor john figure is a is
really a function it's not an individual
yeah yeah this is because yeah because
people are looking for him a thousand
years later like they're you know people
you know christopher columbus is still
looking for for
for press or john or whatever like this
is it really is something like a this
function that exists in the east of a
christian
uh a christian kingdom that could that
we could be connected to
yeah so it's it like you just said it's
really important to understand that this
is a role
right and so the fact that
it um so the actual legend of pressure
john first materializes in
um
prob probably starts to trickle in via
oral accounts especially during the
crusades as peop as people from western
europe are going east a lot
but also just across the trade routes
these rumors have been trickling in for
hundreds of years but they're first
written down in the 12th century um
in a chronicle actually a work of
universal history a deliberate work of
universal history uh by otto of freising
um in his chronic on which he wrote in
about 11 45
and just as a side note i
i would love to actually like
there's not a good translation of the
chronic con into english um and maybe if
i have just excessive amounts of free
time one of these days i'll try to do
one um because i think people might get
a huge kick out of reading an actual
work of of of of medieval universal
history and just see that we're not
making any of this stuff up but
um yeah so in his chronic on he he
recounts
that he had met uh this guy named hugh
um and he was the bishop of basically
the crusader kingdom of edessa
and so he was like a western like a
latin bishop
in syria at that time because of the
crusades
and he ran into hugh at the court of
pope eugene iii
and um
hugh
told um and basically he was on a on an
embassy that eventually results in
pope eugene calling for the second
crusade but hugh tells otto who is
writing this all down in the chronicle
he tells him that prester john
um who is this uh this king of the east
who serves in the dual position of
priest and king
had basically conquered the kingdom of
or the city of um uh
batana which is a very very important
ancient persian uh kingdom
for our city from uh that he'd that he
had conquered it from the islamic
caliphate in a great battle
so there's this rumor that there was
this christian king out there who's sort
of eating away
at the caliphate from from the from the
eastern side
and um
uh but what's what's interesting is that
otto mentions in this
account
that he was supposed to then be marching
out to rescue jerusalem and conquer the
holy land
uh but that the swollen waters of the
tigris river had forced him to return
back to his own country
and um
there is a
an idea here that comes up again in some
of the later prester john accounts which
is there is this christian king of the
east he's conquering
the he's conquering the caliphate but
he probably won't show up at jerusalem
anytime soon so you can't count on his
help
um and i think that it was very
important like they're trying to get
crusades going you know it's very
important to say listen you can't just
count on these guys to do it yourself we
got to do our bit too
um
but um and there may have been some
uh for instance there are several
historians who have connected this with
real historical events um
uh of when the uh the the
uh
one of the khanates um
one of the candidates one of the
mongolian khanates actually did
defeat
um
defeat the seljuk turks
in persia in a pretty large battle about
four years before this account so okay
there probably is like a historical
event you could say
that that kind of ties into this yeah
so already people are going to hear that
it ends up being a connection between
professor john
and the mongols or the these steps and
specifically
between pressure john and the what we
could call the nestorian christians or
the church of the east
under presser john so at this point we
should just say a little bit about this
um
uh most people who follow symbolic
the symbolic world are probably at least
a little bit familiar with the fact that
there was a major church council
called the council of ephesus
which is also sometimes referred to as
the third ecumenical council
and it was at this ecumenical council
that the the theology of
nestorius right who said that
um
uh he said that
mary was not the mother of god that
she's only the mother of christ
right and so that she only let's say
gave birth to his
human uh human nature
not his divine nature
um and this churching was repudiated by
the church at the at the council of
ephesus um uh specifically through the
theology of saint cyril of alexandria uh
who said listen
mothers don't give birth to natures that
give birth to persons right very simple
um and so because of this it is it is it
is meat and right one could say
to call mary the theotokos the the
mother of god the one who gave birth to
god
and uh so the churches that rejected
this
uh which were you know the majority of
churches that rejected this sort of fell
outside of the
the what was really the roman empire the
roman world the roman sphere of
influence at the time the churches that
rejected this became known as the uh
as either as the historian church
historian christians um and some people
say that that's like a pejorative term
we should use that to talk about them
and i i mean i don't know um
i've talked to folks from the church of
the east who who
you know definitely consider nestorius
to be a saint is one of their saints and
identify themselves as historians but um
some people prefer the term true to the
east so
whatever floats your boat people um
and uh and so the church of the eastern
historian church um this is this is the
uh basically the majority of christians
in
persia um what is modern day like iraq
iran and um going all the way to china
and so we talked last time
we talked last time about this
um
this uh
uh for instance raban bar salma who's
this chinese monk who makes a pilgrimage
all the way from beijing
to basically makes it as far as paris
um one of the longest overland journeys
ever recorded actually um and uh makes
it to paris and while he's there in
paris he actually communes king edward
the first at mass
so
i mean that's a pretty pretty wild story
um but
um
um he was a he was what we consider an
historian and the christian missions in
china were
historian yes yeah and there's a lot of
really good documentation now about
the
basically there was a there was a a
relatively successful in the story in
mission uh where uh you know under a
certain dynasty under the tong dynasty
where christianity was highly tolerated
um in ancient china and so and so it
grew and flourished and you can like
look at early documents where it seems
like they're really struggling to speak
to the chinese people in their own
language and then there are later
documents where you can see they've done
the basically the same things that
christianity did with the language of
greek philosophy they do that with like
the language of taoist philosophy and
are able to
are able to more successfully talk about
christ in a way that the chinese people
can kind of comprehend um and then there
is a big wave of persev persecution and
it almost gets completely wiped out and
then it has another resurgence under the
mongols exactly and so part of the
mongols part of the people associated
with the mongols or that were part of
the mongol tribes would have been
historian certain yeah in sections
certain tribes and groups and they're
the big kind of
yeah the nestorians were never a um they
were never a majority in the mongols but
there were there were whole tribes of
mongols who were historian christians
and there were um a lot of uh you you
have the same kind of thing going on in
early roman history where it's like the
majority of romans aren't christians
but they're like a suspicious number of
wives and mothers of powerful roman men
who
who are who are i don't know it's like
uh it's kind of a kind of a thing about
christianity and mothers i don't know
you know it's uh and so you have the
same kind of thing happening in the
khanates so there were there were whole
tribes
of of um there were whole tribes of the
mongols who were christians and actually
marched to battle behind the sign of the
cross um
and this is actually this is an
important detail because this is one of
the things there is in the 1160s there's
this letter that circulates called the
letter of presser john that circulates
all throughout western europe and it's
it describes the glories of the kingdom
of pressure john and his armies and
things like this and the part of the
reason that i spent so much time talking
about the alexander romance and the
letter of alexander to aristotle in our
previous video
is because
a lot of this a lot of the this letter
is sort of you could say cribbed from
the alexander stuff and some of his crib
from other sources like the acts of
thomas right and so there's this
basically we you know you could say the
western world and i'm including
like constantinople in the western world
in this particular frame
had a had a vocabulary for talking about
the great king of the east and so they
took that vocabulary and they used it to
describe this this sort of legendary
figure of presser john
but one of the things that's described
in there is you know his his army is
marching to battle behind the sign of a
cross which you can you can see being
like a kind of a comforting thing
for uh for crusaders and for other
people uh who are fighting in the middle
east themselves marching to battle
behind the sign of the cross and then
they hear hey there's somebody else way
over there who's doing that too but but
there there is a historical reality like
from a modern historical perspective
there's a reality behind that which is
there there really were mongols who were
marching to battle behind the strength
of the cross yeah and lots and lots of
famous
um
uh
descendants of genghis khan for instance
um several of his grandsons uh
sons-in-law
um daughter-in-law uh who is uh who is
an historian christian
um so there are lots of there are lots
of historian christians and actually one
or two of these historian christian
bishops who actually
converted to calcidonian christianity
and uh did not go super well for them
when they did that but um
it is the thing that happened so
there's a lot more that could be said
about this but for our purposes it's
just important to understand
this and i mean the thing is most most
people
maybe don't know very much about the
mongols at all other than that you know
they were scary and they invaded and
genghis khan and like they've seen mulan
um you know whatever although i think in
the mulan cartoon they're actually
fighting the huns because that was like
a less politically dangerous uh
uh
thing it needs to use yeah
yeah um
but
all this to say the the
the
there was a significant nestorian or
church of the east christian minority
among the mongols uh during this entire
period and this
this
this led to
lots of alliances between
the
uh the land crusader kingdoms or the the
let's call them the franks because
that's fun um
but uh uh but i mean those alliances are
called the the franco mongolian alliance
right yeah um because there's a there's
an embassy there was an ambassador and
all the way to france one of the
ambassadors and there are texts there
are letters that you can read and the
king asks
ask the ambassador like how's president
john doing he's like oh he's doing fine
it's like yeah he doesn't think he's not
created that he exists it's not just
that like for instance uh uh doku's
cartoon who's the wife of huluga khan
and the mother of a bakker khan right
with uh hulu khan hulago hulagu khan
there we go being the guy that sucks
baghdad right so this is his wife um she
and uh her um
[Music]
her mom i think
i might have that wrong it might have
been her one of her daughters but uh
they're referred to
no it's it's she is she and she and like
a cousin or something that's an another
female relative of hers they're referred
to in letters to the french and in
letters to the king of con uh the
emperor of constantinople they are
referred to as being the daughters of
professor john
huh like like and and actually
do we know their parents who they're who
they're i i have no idea
her daughter
or sorry her son abaku khan
marries maria
pelo peologina
of the byzantine emperor
michael viii
so so literally at one point there was a
marriage alliance between
the
the the
mongolian khanate
and then a byzantine princess like so at
one point the khan was the son-in-law of
the byzantine emperor yeah that's a
thing that happened which is crazy it's
wild right well it can make you on it
can help you understand a little more
what
what what's going on or why it isn't
these types of legends
because they're difficult because
they're so vague and they move around
that's why they appear also in this kind
of mythological form because there's
something real that's happening but it's
also hard to point down because it's so
slippery uh that it ends up boiling into
this character it's like oh they we
can't we can't talk about all this these
weird mongolian tribes and these
christians among them it's like okay
professor john this is the way we talk
about it and so
it can help people understand also why
things appear in mythological forms yeah
because it's a way to talk about
uh
talk about phenomena that it's sometimes
hard to encapsulate yeah because there's
too much detail like like even me trying
to describe something like the frankish
mongolian alliance or the byzantine
mongolian alliances or the ways that
they coordinated together to defeat the
the caliphate and you know all this
different stuff like there's just too
much detail but i can basically just say
presto john you know and like like it
kind of it kind of actually
encapsulates all of these different
scenarios
and so one of the crazy things that that
we mentioned together before we started
is that we have to remember that the
apocalypse of pseudomethodius is also a
nestorian syrian
type
not not an historian but oh it's not
um maybe maybe
a probably non-uh
probably non-chalcedonian yeah
yeah so so to ivy just a little bit of
like uh uh
so you have the the the
third ecumenical council which is
rejected by the historian churches
um and then you had the fourth
ecumenical council which is rejected by
the groups that we so we now call like
the oriental orthodox so that's a really
recent label right
like the cops and the ethiopians and the
armenians
and um and also some of some of the
other uh saint thomas christians are
like that the syrian versus uh syria is
how that's usually yeah so that you have
like syrians who are non-calcedonian and
then assyrians who were who rejected the
council of ephesus but did actually
formally accept the council of calciton
so
it's a it's kind of a an interesting
kind of a thing so so then the the the
epoxy of the pseudomythologies would
have been the non-cacidonian yeah yeah
yeah which which again we talked about
this because in the apocalypse of
pseudo-methodius the place where
byzantium and ethiopia come back
together happens at calcidon in yeah i
remember yeah yeah
yeah
so um
yeah so so all of this is to kind of say
uh we should probably at this point talk
about
the really big place where this prophecy
kind of comes to pass right so this idea
is you have these barbarian kingdoms out
of the north these monsters on the edge
of the world and if you just read
the way that for instance the the the
muslim uh caliphates the umayyad
caliphate and the other ones the way
that they experienced the mongols when
the mongols invaded
they understood the mongols
as being the wrath of god um and in fact
um
again genghis khan much like attila the
hung genghis khan leaned into this so
when he would show up to invade
somewhere
there's this great quote it's my
favorite genghis khan quote and it goes
something like
your sins must have been really terrible
for the god of heaven to have set me
loose upon you
like just
yeah and even even the even the like the
really pro-christian or at least
christian friendly cons
when they would send embassies to talk
to the pope or to the you know the king
of france or something they actually
started out uh interacting mainly with
the pope and then at some point they
realized i think it's actually the king
of france that is running europe and so
they they switched to just talking to
him but they would send these embassies
and they would be like uh yeah the god
of heaven has ordained that you're going
to bow the knee before us so you should
probably get on with that and we'd be
more than happy to help you with your
problem in the middle east but you
should probably get on with you know uh
sending tribute please please uh please
address your tribute payments too here's
here's here's the address you know kind
of a thing uh really i mean even the
really uh the friendliest mongolian
embassies were like this yeah you know
and um
so they saw themselves they saw
themselves functioning in this kind of
way as the left hand of god and they
leaned into it
um they saw themselves as the judgment
of god or the gods
uh mongolia's society is pretty
pluralistic
um sometimes sometimes but um but they
saw themselves basically as the judgment
of god on these different on these
different uh
countries and so this kind of culminates
for instance
in the destruction of baghdad
um
and this direction of
baghdad under uh uh
hulagu khan is
probably
one of the
most scarring
and most complete
military victories slash genocides in
the history of humanity yeah um
unless you've read a lot of literature
from this period you cannot understand i
mean uh the city of baghdad was an
incredibly developed city
extremely wealthy extremely advanced
extremely decadent all these things
and um very powerful and when it was
destroyed it was cataclysmic you know it
was it was like it was analogous to the
fall of constantinople for the muslim
world yeah but even much worse because
yeah
he actually was raised to the ground
yeah the libraries were burned they were
like you know mounds of skulls like it
was just insane
yeah i'm not even going to describe the
atrocities
because they were really bad
um but you can go and look this stuff up
um yeah i mean just like
i somebody did the math one time on how
many uh
i mean this here's the thing about the
mongols like people don't understand the
romans were also good at this
um is is that the mongols and the romans
both worked out because you'll read
they massacred this many people this
many tens of thousands of people over
this many hours
so then like you'd have to start
like you can do the math on that and
figure how many people per hour would
you have to kill
to massacre that number of people and
you realize that at some point
these people i mean the mongols were not
at some point they figured out the most
efficient ways of quickly killing large
numbers of people i don't know how to
say it like like we're talking genocides
yeah
unprecedented in human history up to
that point
and um
yeah so somebody's done the math on the
siege of baghdad and like how many
people they had to be
slaughtering per hour but one of the
things that happens in the siege of
baghdad is that
doku's cartoon you know this christian
wife of the khan she intercedes
on the behalf of the nestorian
christians
living in the city of baghdad at the
time
and
they are largely spared the destruction
i don't think they're totally spared i
mean uh you know sacking a city is real
messy jonathan uh
but um but but they are largely spare
the destruction of the city so this is a
way that this this this you say this
legend of pressure john
um
manifested itself in this
in this uh
kind of ultimate or final way yeah it's
really kind of dark way but yeah in a
dark way yeah um and and i will say
after this the mongols and the
byzantines and the franks like did
continue to work together
and there are differing you know over
the next two or three generations and
there are kind of differing
uh
perspectives from modern day scholars
and historians as to
how effective their efforts were or were
not um but if people want to read about
that stuff they can they can go out and
look it up so it's important for people
to to understand that there are images
of hulagu and his wife or hulago and his
mother i think that are represented as
constantine and helen holding holding
across your cross in the center yeah
yeah i mean
again this is wild stuff and uh
people should not for a moment take away
that you know like we're endorsing
something like genocide in the name of
christ right or something like that
because it's not at all a that's not at
all what we're talking about and b like
you would just have to understand
the
this is the symbolism of of of the edge
like the gates of alexander being open
this is what happens
and
um
and it's something that happened
historically
um
and you know obviously in this dark and
terrible way it was an awful awful time
for probably everyone involved
but it did happen and um
the way that uh from the perspective
this jerusalem-centric perspective of
history that we've been talking about of
understanding the world the way that
they describe that was was
through these legends of pressure john
this king of the east this christian
king of the east um which which by the
way um
uh doku's cut uh
or sorry uh uh hulagu khan himself was
not a christian no
in fact he i
uh he was he was a shamanist and and
converted probably to buddhism at the
end of his life despite the wishes of
his wife so he wasn't a christian yeah
nobody nobody's really saying he was
but he was participating in this pattern
of presser john that was so important
to
to the
sort of
you could say franco byzantine world at
the time
so so the last thing i want to mention
maybe before we we we finish is that
there is also an interesting and
important understanding of this kind of
wind or fire that comes from the north
and when we we talk about how it is both
a force of destruction but also a force
of renewal is a way that we can also see
if we look at the historical precedent
of how that works so you can see that
what happens when the people come down
from the north usually is that they
bring something like strength
but they don't bring identity their
identity is mixed their identity is
confused it's a mixture of tribes it's a
mixture of religions it's all this kind
of wild kind of chaos and then they come
in from the north they destroy and then
they usually become fertile ground for
something new and what ends up happening
is that the strength of these northern
invaders gets taken up by the identity
of the people they invaded and that's
like the weirdest thing but it's
important to understand that so when the
germanic goths and and all these
germanic people come down and try to
destroy rome they end up becoming the
defenders of rome and end up becoming
the continuation of the roman empire
when charlemagne uh you know becomes
holy roman empire and all these northern
people kind of take up the roman
identity we see the same when the the
vikings are coming down the norm they
they they're they they're given normandy
they convert to to christianity and then
they become the place of strength for
western europe becomes in normandy and
and the norm has become the strength we
see the same with the russians
scandinavians come down to russia they
convert to orthodox christianity
the same with the mongols the mongols
come down they become the emperors of
china they become the emperors of india
they become
all these these powerful figures but
that don't actually preserve their
mongolian identity yeah end up taking up
the identity of islam or buddhism or of
the different groups that they encounter
and so this is a type of interaction
that we often
struggle to understand we don't think in
these terms but it's important to see
that this is a type of interaction which
is possible and which exists and also
understanding that strength and identity
are not the same thing power and
identity are not the same things uh and
that that sometimes even a minority that
has identity
can take over a very very powerful group
uh it's not just about strength and
about military might
yeah i mean there's there's a
there's a plethora of historical
examples of this where you have a
a small but powerful minority who brings
in strength
and then adopts the
adopts the identity of the larger group
such they such as they become like the
new guardians of what it really means to
to to fully embody that identity there's
a whole string all the best emperors of
a certain period of the roman empire
were illyrians who were all
barbarians but they were
power they were skilled generals they
were effective leaders um and so what
they were able to do is actually embody
roman identity in a way that the romans
themselves had lost the ability to do um
there are lots of there are lots of
other examples of this as well that you
can find throughout history um and yeah
i mean it's important to say that
er the the khanate the ilkana destroyed
baghdad but the golden horde which is
the longest lasting
remnant or the longest lasting part of
the mongolian empire uh and of course
obviously ruled over
you know
russia and lots of other orthodox
territories for a long time
and then the church
yeah but the golden horde was muslim
right they they adopted they eventually
i adopted the identity of the people
that they conquered
um
and uh i mean this is this is powerful
even within christianity right now right
not just in orthodoxy but in pretty much
every
every kind of christianity that is
um
you know that that sees itself in a
traditional way let's say we have we
have lots of people who are coming in
from really difficult backgrounds really
rough backgrounds um who were not
christians before who were not uh
uh who were maybe even the enemies of
christianity before and then as they're
converting they are uh they're becoming
really vocal defenders of their faith
and maybe not always in that you know
people who have been christians a long
time they're like oh man i don't you
shouldn't talk to people that way or
something like that you know but but we
we need to understand what's going on
here um that this is actually something
that's really vital and important in
terms of how we are
um
sort of you could say like this new
strength this new potential that's
coming into christianity right at this
moment yeah so
yeah
all right folks so i think i think we
done enough talking about the crazy
history of these of gag and magog so i
appreciated everything is there a last
thing you want to say richard before um
yeah it's just uh i i think something
i'd like to circle back on a little bit
is
in our previous video one of the things
that you mentioned that that i think is
worth really thinking about is uh and it
relates to what you just said about
strength encountering identity is that
the most honest and sincere way
to encounter
the edge right is to is to fully embody
the identity of the the thing that you
belong to
um
as we uh you know many of your viewers
are christians
um and so i'll just speak to christians
for a moment like as we are
as we are encountering you know the
monsters on the edge of the world this
strange place of hybridity that we're
moving into
uh this influx of new converse to
christianity which i am all for okay
um this new this this conflict this this
influx of new converts to christianity
this influx of
of new ways of i mean the internet
itself the fact that you're listening
this video on youtube
guys that's a
that's a weird thing right that's a
that's a thing that's happening kind of
you know the ways that the internet sort
of functions as the as the end of the
world right um
as
as we're doing all of this
the the best thing that we can do the
most powerful thing we can do
um as we encounter
all of these things at the edge is is
not to like freak out or panic it's not
to
it's not to try to uh
you know exclude other people from the
gospel
uh who really desire really need it
because you know
they're gonna lower the property value
so to speak of our neighborhood things
like this the most important thing that
we can do
is to
fully embody christ right um
is to and the way the way that we do
this i mean this is the big
paradox of christianity
um is that you know christ says that
you know at the last judgment we're
going to stand before him and he's going
to say hey why didn't you visit visit me
when i was in prison
right why didn't you feed me when i was
hungry why didn't you clothe me when i
was naked
and we're gonna say
lord we never encountered you in any of
those situations because we weren't
looking for you out there
and
so this is the thing as as we encounter
this stuff we need to fully embody our
identity as christians go to liturgy
read the lives of the saints be a
christian like us as thoroughly and as
authentically as you can be because it's
the only way that
as we encounter the destructive forces
uh of the culture around us that's the
only way that we're going to kind of
survive that and we might not survive it
in terms of keeping the empires we've
been trying to build for ourselves
um
but christianity always wins through
martyrdom
so
all right everybody on that note thanks
for your attention and uh we'll be back
with more with more universal history
very soon bye-bye
this episode is part of a series of
discussions i've had with richard roland
on universal history you can find a list
of all these episodes on my youtube
channel where you can find them also in
my podcast stream from the symbolic
world on your different podcast
platforms make sure to check out
richard's second podcast which he hosts
in collaboration with father andrew
damick called amman sewell which looks
at the relationship between tolkien and
orthodoxy this podcast has also inspired
me some ideas for creating some images
whether it be the king under the
mountain whether it be the grail
or beautiful ethiopian traditions i've
created some products which you can find
on my store the symbolicworld.store
and there will probably be more of those
to come very soon so stay tuned this
conversation is ongoing and there is
still very much to explore in the
universal history